[Music]
Governor Ron DeSantis has faced
criticism recently for flying immigrants
from Texas to Martha's Vineyard these
immigrants have reportedly been lied to
about housing and work opportunities and
have been sent across the country by
DeSantis as a publicity stunt he has
used these vulnerable people to try to
gain voters and when I heard about it it
made me so mad that I wanted to roast
him but he deserves worse than that he
deserves to be read for Filth and he
deserves to have it done by an expert
which brings us to a segment called an
Exquisite drag by an Exquisite drag
[Applause]
[Music]
Rhonda Santos you attending Clan Hood
flying people was your big idea you
probably booked that [ __ ] on spirit
because you have the spirit of old ass
racist from a Quentin Tarantino film
[Applause]
actually I bet you booked that [ __ ] on
Frontier
because that's a whole new frontier of
stupidity
you are so racist that you probably hate
your own last name
okay
let's get Petty
you look like God Smiley had a love
child with a Weeble wobble
you look like Tom Holland after he was
found at the bottom of the river
you look like you couldn't lift a gallon
of milk yet milk is the only thing you
drink
I have no way to prove this but I am
confident in saying that you don't wash
your hands when you pee
you look like the term basic [ __ ] came
to life it was raised by bigots that are
probably kissing cousins
you look like a missionary both the
person and the sexual position
[Applause]
you are such a gigantic [ __ ]
that if you posted your face on Grindr
it would be considered two obscene
[Applause]
you hack ass whack ass no Talent no
policy having [ __ ] ass Bernie cross
come to life
[Applause]
[ __ ] I hope you get covered in your
booty hoe anyway
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone catch jiggly in Translation on
out TV and on drag race Philippines on
well presents Plus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]